exactly we just ran from the club with
Fabby Fabiano congratulations what an
impressive Victory and you have
immediately the question from Peter
swedler who just asked how do you do
it you should explain you know I was so
nervous during this game I I can't
explain at some point because I um I've
played a lot of games against Richard
where he out plays me in this sort of
style and uh and also I felt the
pressure of the tournament situation
like do I play for a win but I don't
want to take huge risks of course
because uh the worst thing is to lose uh
and and to miss out on everything but of
course lenier maybe let's say he gets
some winning chances I also have to
watch out for that so I had a lot of
thoughts going through my head and
around this
moment uh like I started to feel like
I've been getting outplayed and I
thought he would just take on C3 or
something and okay it's probably equal I
mean in many cases but then when he
allowed this Knight E4 suddenly I
started to get very optimistic mhm
because I thought okay now Knight D6 is
an idea uh he was hoping for some
tactics but I didn't see exactly how
they're working okay I always have to be
careful for Knight E3 and yeah then I
was thinking okay C5 is very sharp
because of Knight C5 Knight E3 something
happens I don't know what so somewhere
around this moment lineer finished his
game right so what were your thoughts at
this at this time yeah no I was still
thinking okay let's um let's not go
crazy or anything uh of course yeah the
worst is is that I lose and and miss out
also on the playoff or against laner but
already at this moment I felt like I'm
out of room
I thought this AME there's absolutely no
risk for white I mean like worst case he
equalizes somehow best case he's in
serious danger which is what I felt
because his Knights are very awkward I
always have the option of H3 so if he
goes somewhere like Bishop to A3
suddenly I have um probably H3 at some
moment and uh and also my first
intention was something like H3 Knight
F6 Knight D6 because I thought this
tactic and then I saw that after Knight
C8 he can take Rook C8 this is very
important and I didn't feel like I have
everything but then I have anything so
then I saw this rook dc1 and it really
attracted me because I'm keeping the
option of H6 and Knight D6 but also I'm
threatening C6 so felt very dangerous
here and then he went for this sequence
I wasn't sure here there's like very
tempting Bishop H4 as well um but I
couldn't see the way forward here H3 KN
H6 it looks so weird but uh and and then
yeah it's something collapsed in in his
time trouble but it's so to defend this
yeah I mean especially he had not so
much time with his clock at this moment
um yeah you said that you felt pressure
today and it's me it was very important
game so finally you reached your goal
this is the next one as you told me a
few few days ago now you have to win the
tournament how does it feel I mean all
this well I I actually remember last
year because uh last year Ali RZA came
he won the rapid and Blitz and he won
the singfield cup and he won the
grandest Tour and I remember thinking
this is amazing to like I can't ever
dream of doing this and this year
somehow I managed to do exactly what he
did so he inspired you in a way well I
couldn't can't even say inspired because
I couldn't even expect that I would be
able to reach this these Heights but uh
um yeah somehow it all worked out
perfectly yeah and you know this year
you were winning so many events and um
let's say we were just following it on
on the on our screens all the events all
the prizes you have won um what has
changed in your life let's say or your
in your approach to the game that you
think helped you to succeeds this year I
I can't really say because at the start
of the year I I had some rough results
some really rough results um in for
example vikin in the American Cup and I
wasn't feeling like I was playing so
amazing um but somehow things things
worked out I I did start to um work more
than I was like let's say during covid
years um this took a lot of my um
motivation out motivation to work and
also to play and now I feel like I've
regained it so I'm I really enjoy
working on chess again and I enjoy
playing even with the stress which is of
course always a there's always a lot of
stress but I I still really enjoy
playing um and you know sometimes it's
like this you have waves of good or bad
um at the moment I'm going through a
period of good results and hopefully it
continues yeah who who was in your team
who was helping you during this events
yeah so I I've been working here um with
a a player who I've worked for already
many months Gregorio parin MH so we work
very well together uh he was also with
me at the World Cup and um uh and at the
buest Grand chest Tour event so so we've
already worked for for several months I
don't think it's a secret that I'm
saying this because we've obviously been
seen together and uh yeah he's he's a
he's an excellent chess player also
excellent um understanding of the game
so I I feel like I've benefited from our
work yeah and um now the plans have to
ask you before the candidates
tournaments candidates tournament what
are you going to do what what is the
plan what will be your preparation uh
well this I can't say uh fully first of
all I don't know exactly yet I have some
preliminary plans but nothing really uh
written in
stone but um also I probably wouldn't
want to share all my all my uh training
plans let's say but of course yeah there
there will be plenty of uh preparation
since it's everyone's going to be taking
it super seriously it's a you know it's
a chance of um of a lifetime for many
players and you don't get many
opportunities to play so it's always a
privilege to be able to play the
candidates but you will not play in
vague so where do you plan to play
before the candidates any any news you
know I I am playing an event in February
but I don't think I should say because I
I don't know if it's been officially
announced and and I don't know if maybe
the organizers want to to announce it
themselves so I I don't think I should
say this but it will be an interesting
very interesting event in February uh
with many many great players and I'm
looking forward to that and um I don't
know about the plans for maybe maybe the
American Cup next year I don't know
exactly when the dates will be or um or
what the plan is but also maybe that
will be on the cards before the
candidates we'll we we'll see I really
don't know and um yeah I'm not sure
there's there's well coming up very soon
an event in Toronto I'm playing so like
in one week yeah that's a big one with
uh Magnus Hikaru Ali Resa Maxim U
exactly not back many of the best
players in the world so my last last
question like how are you going to
celebrate now I think really it's time
to celebrate yeah I I'll probably um
yeah I'll probably have a drink
tonight good good good so all the best
for you Fabby thank you so much for all
those interviews and for fantastic
playing the tournament congratulations
once again thank you all the best and
we're going back to the studio to our
thank you Anastasia and once again a
huge congratulations to Fabiano Carana
who is the winner of the sink field cup
and he wins
$100,000 as well as taking the grand
chest to points of 13 lenia Dominguez
also wild card in second place was
$65,000 to the good and in third place
it was Wesley so taking home
48,000 and how does this all translate
to the
grandest final standings well we knew
two days ago that Fabiana Carana was
going to be the grand chess torch
champion and he's got the highest ever
score of 46 out of 52 points I think it
was something absolutely magnificent but
in second place it was Maxim Vash lra
who collected 28 grand chestor points
and in third place Wesley
so and these prizes include uh the bonus
money of 100,000 for first in the grand
chest Tor 50,000 second and
25,000 third
yes and this is our champion and this is
our champion Fabiano caruana singfield
Cup champion Grand test tour Champion St
Louis rapid and blitz winner what a year
that Fabiano has had simply spectacular
simply